bonjour et bienvenue sur france 24
pour une interview exclusive avec simone
gbagbo qui est en duplex depuis abidjan
merci d'être avec nous madame
vous venez de lancer votre parti le
mouvement des générations capables lors
une question toute simple mais
importante pourquoi avez vous décidé de
lancer ce parti dont vous avez pris la
présidence
mais pourquoi pas
nous avons à passer un nouveau contrat
social avec la population ivoirienne
notre pays est à la croisée des chemins
depuis plusieurs années vous le savez
est donc un nouveau parti c'est une
nouvelle offre d'actions politiques
alors c'est un nouveau parti de gauche
mais si je regarde le paysage politique
ivoirien il y a déjà des partis à gauche
évidemment le front populaire ivoirien
que vous aviez fondé avec laurent gbagbo
il ya le nouveau parti de laurent gbagbo
le ppa c'est y qui a été lancé il y a
quelques mois est ce que ça ne va pas
disperser la gauche ivoirienne
ou bien alors ça va aider d'approché du
foie aliens à se remettre plus debout
voyez c'est une nouvelle offre est donc
on espère qu'avec cela va pouvoir encore
pressés suture et mieux se souder mais
alors quelles sont vos priorités à vous
maintenant maintenant que vous prenez un
rôle politique direct quelles sont vos
priorités mal à gbagbo
vous savez la pyrite et de tout parti
c'est de transformer les conditions de
vie des populations
mais ma priorité m priorité aujourd'hui
c'est d'aider à ramener la confiance
entre les différents groupes ivoiriens
les différences ethniques existant côte
d'ivoire ramener la paix ramener la
réconciliation et puis
2 à transformer les mentalités des
ivoiriens ça c'est vraiment une très
grosse
transformer les mentalités des duvalier
a fait un ensemble de travailler pour
les changements de condition de vite en
quoi dieu mais les résultats macro
économique de la côte d'ivoire sont bon
pourquoi est ce que vous dites qu'elle
est à la croisée des chemins la côte
d'ivoire la situation était bien plus
compliqué bien plus tendu bien plus
meurtrière et vous le savez vous-mêmes
spécialement il ya une dizaine d'années
la macroéconomie là c'est de ça qu'on
mange c'est pas ça que les populations
la macroéconomie
ce que nous voyons dans le pays c'est
qu'il ya beaucoup de misère beaucoup de
difficultés beaucoup d'exclusion il faut
pouvoir recentrer tout le développement
du pays autour de cette question là et
donc nous estimons que nous pouvoir
porter notre part à ce niveau alors
quelles sont vos ambitions parce qu un
parti c'est fait pour présenter des
idées mais il faut des militants il faut
de l'argent et il faut des victoires
électorales quelle est l'ambition de
votre mouvement madame gbagbo
nous sommes un parti politique tous
partis politiques se donne pour objectif
de participer à toutes les élections
pour mignoni
le pouvoir est allé gagner oui et à la
gagne mais nous sommes très optimistes
vous savez et donc participer à toutes
les élections depuis le municipal
jusqu'aux présidentielles nous sommes
décidés à à le faire et à y réussir
alors lors de votre congrès fondateur il
y a quelques jours
vous aviez invité d'autres partis de
gauche on à noter toutefois que le pp
asei de laurent gbagbo a refusé votre
invitation en tout cas il n'est pas venu
vous même vous aviez refusé d'assister
au congrès fondateur du pp asei en
octobre dernier à abidjan est ce à dire
que le divorce est consommé
en tout cas au niveau politique entre
vous et laurent gbagbo
vous savez vous pas être trop pessimiste
elle ne peut jamais dire que
complètement tout est rompu
définitivement on ne dit jamais cela
mais il est évident que pour l'instant
chaque fait son chemin et puis l'avenir
nous dira un quel soleil les
possibilités quelles sont les raisons
d'une alliance possible ou non ça ça
c'est la venue ce que nous le dira mais
est ce que vous regrettez l'absence d'un
représentant du parti de laurent gbagbo
à votre congrès fondateur si vous les
avez invité ils sont pas venus on
imagine que ça a dû vous vous décevoir
bien sûr on a toujours dessus quand on
lance une invitation que la réponse ne
vient pas positivement mais on n'était
pas non plus étonné de cette absence on
n'a pas été étonné de 70 ans mais je me
dis que
la venue nous dira que soient les
possibilités d'alliance avec le pp ac ou
non mais chacun fait son chemin c'est ça
qu'est le plus important risque une
alliance qui assemble
à lisier à lady anne a dit
non je disais que pourvu que au final le
pays la population en sorte grandi c'est
ça qui est l'essentiel est ce que vous
vous posez en opposante frontale
alassane ouattara ou est ce que vous
pourriez aussi travaillé avec son régime
bessalah nous nous définissons comme un
parti dans l'opposition
et donc nous allons pouvoir
jouer notre rôle de parti d'opposition
un rôle critique mais également de
proposition à chaque fois que nous
estimons que les propositions sont
nécessaires nous allons le faire nous
nous positionnons pas en alliés du
rhdp
ça c'est certain mais si pour une raison
pour nous une autre pour un acte
historique où il est nécessaire de
s'asseoir et de discuter et de
s'entendre on verra on n'est pas de
forcer les de l'opposition mais on n'est
pas non plus la écrire pour être un
parti allié actuellement ou where h
n'était alors vous avez parlé de la
nécessité de changer les mentalités des
ivoiriens évidemment la question de la
réconciliation
se pose est ce que quand même il ya eu
donc levé le retour au pays de laurent
gbagbo il ya des exilés politiques sont
rentrés des prisonniers qui ont été
libérés il ya eu des rencontres entre
les anciens président gbagbo bédié avec
l'actuel président ouattara qui a
récemment gracié laurent gbagbo les
choses quand même vont dans le bon sens
où est ce que pour vous tout cela n'est
que superficielle
ce sont des pas ce sont des pas qui ont
été prises et il faut même il faut même
inscrit dans cette parle à moi-même ma
libération du plus haut j'ai bénéficié
quand même
d'une
armistice qui a permis donc de me mettre
dehors et d'effacer tout ce qui ce qui
mettait le prochain mais ce sont des pas
mais le plus important reste à faire
encore parce que jusqu'aujourd'hui je
n'ai pas encore vu de
de débat ou de décisions permettant à
ceux qui ont été spoliés de tous leurs
biens la d'être de recevoir institutions
de tout ce qu'ils ont fait j'ai pas vu
non plus de soucis s'asseyant pour lui
pourquoi est ce que ce pays est entrain
crise pourquoi est ce qu'il ya eu la
guerre dans notre pays il faut bien que
à ce niveau là la vérité soit dite et
que on pousse à pâtir de cette vérité-là
panser les plaies
raccommodé ce qui est raccordable
fait de l'institution qui s'imposent et
de manière à ce que les victimes sortent
des difficultés et que de véritables
vous reçoit également
traité hambourg d'une manière à ce que
la toute la vérité étant établie en pis
aller de l'avant de l'aspect alors s'est
pas fait en cette affaire
c'est bien compris en parlant de d'aller
de l'avant on va on va regarder un petit
peu vers l'avenir et vous imaginez bien
que je pense à l'élection de 2025 alors
tout d'abord une question sur un projet
de loi qui a été introduit à l'assemblée
pour limiter l'âge pour être candidat à
la présidence à 75 ans ce qui
éliminerait de fait
le président ouattara bédié l'an gbagbo
mais si j'ai bien compris vous aussi
est-ce que vous êtes contre cette
limitation
moi je suis contre ce genre de lois et
qui font de limitation je suis contre
regardez en europe le gardien en
amérique il n'y a aucune loi limitant
l'âge de candidature présidentielle
pourquoi vous êtes dans la démocratie
beaucoup plus ancienne que la nôtre
pourtant donc moi je suis contre ce type
de limitation là maintenant le débat à
six il arrive à l'assemblée nationale
qu'il sait faire et puis la population
ivoirienne pourra décider alors
évidemment se pose la question de votre
destin vous avez donc décidé de plonger
dans l'arène politique
dorénavant vous êtes présidente d'un
parti la présidente d'un parti qui va
concourir des élections vous l'avez dit
vous-même vous avez mentionné la
présidentielle et évidemment ça pose la
question de votre candidature à 2025
allez vous être candidate une présidence
de la république en côte d'ivoire
là que je ne vous dis ni oui ni non en
2025 que le mgc sera
candidat maintenant qui va porter les
couleurs du mgc c'est le parti qui le
décidera pour l'instant tout ce que je
peux vous dire c'est que les mjc aura un
candidat aux présidentielles de 2005
mais si vous êtes élue présidente a
après des années à avoir réfléchi à se
lancer j'allais dire seul en politique
sans laurent gbagbo on peut imaginer que
c'est votre volonté on plonge dans
l'arène politique pour gagner pour
gagner la mère de toutes les élections
c'est à dire la présidentielle simone
gbagbo
viennent à l'arène politique de paix tel
mal d'années
je ne suis pas sorti à un moment donné
de l'arène politique je suis sous une
forme ou sous une autre et donc je
demeure dans l'arène politique et j'ai
dit que si mon parti décide que je suis
la personne la mieux placée en tant que
présidente du parti pour vous les battre
à ce niveau là bon je le ferai je n'ai
eu aucune difficulté à pour cela mais si
le parti décide qu'il faut quelqu'un
d'autre et bien j'aime alignera ce que
le parti décidera c'est une militante
très disciplinés vous savez
et sur ces paroles je tiens à vous
remercier de votre
interview exclusive accordée aujourd'hui
à france 24 depuis abidjan merci à vous
de l'avoir suivi sur nos antennes
restez-y pour plus d'informations
[Musique]